morning John you know what I said that I
will ask the charge to my camcorder well
I did and I don't have any way to record
this video so I'm lucky enough to have a
lot of footage that I took all that mom
and dad's house some of it quite graphic
I'm gonna sound like two girls and one
cub or anything like look these are baby
chicks and these are just pigs and these
are two girl pigs mounting each other
nothing wrong with that but coming up is
something that is a little bit
disturbing
it is a goat giving birth to a baby goat
and while it's not two girls in one cup
material I would not mind if you people
pause the video right now and then film
yourself watching this because I want to
see your reaction because I couldn't see
my own and frankly I would like to have
been able to see my own reaction to this
goat birth in my opinion what you're
about to hear sounds like a Velociraptor
puking and what you're about to see
looks like a goat giving birth to a baby
goat so pause now and record if you
would like to show me your reaction
otherwise either stop the video right
now get ready for some serious freaky
goat birthing it was gold giving birth
to a baby goat giving birth oh god
that's really really gross it was God
giving birth to a baby goat the miracle
of life right before my eyes and all I
wanna do is turn the camera off and
hidings goat giving birth to a baby goat
Oh God
that's wrong
oh and of course no-go birthing video
would be complete without a techno remix
hit Michael Aranda
[Music]
that's more
thank you ever so much to Michael Aranda
for doing that amazing arrangement and
thank you as well to the Katherine for
harmonizing with me because I can never
figure out how to harmonize with myself
and finally and most importantly thank
you to Christy the goat for giving birth
to not one not two not three but four
beautiful baby goats on that day my life
will never be the same
John dftba